[Music]
on this Tuesday night flu season fears
new stress on an already strained Health
Care system this fall winter is going to
be extremely extremely challenging how
you can protect yourself and who's most
at risk a matter of life and death we
found that it had metastasized very
quickly the barrier some women face in
getting tested for breast cancer a
professional athlete's uncertain fate in
Iran I believe that that punishment will
come the escalating concerns for this
competitive climber's well-being and
Mackenzie Scott's constant goal to give
the Billionaire's generous donation
mission
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
Canada's cold and flu season is ramping
up and experts warn it could be severe
for the last two years pandemic
restrictions largely kept viruses at Bay
but there are signs the flu is poised to
Stage its first real covet era comeback
in Australia where the flu season has
now passed data shows influenza hit
early and it hit hard peaking in June it
was the country's worst flu season in
five years many hospitals in this
country say cases are coming in earlier
than normal and health experts are
warning children are particularly at
risk Janie moroccer has our top story
tonight
inside this Ontario Children's Hospital
pediatrician Rod Lim is watching the
makings of a perfect storm capacity
concerns staff shortages and now an
aggressive cold and flu season I don't
know any person who's working in the
emergency services who does not worry
tremendously about what this fall winter
is ahead for us especially among
children who have not been exposed to
viruses for two or three years now
already some pediatric hospitals are
reporting increased admissions in
respiratory illnesses tonight
somewhat tight in Ottawa the Children's
Hospital's inpatient occupancy is at 120
percent when we're backed up in the
emergency department we can't get
admissions up to the floor keeping in
mind that you know most of these kids
have something infectious and so they
need um special rooms the hospital
expanded a special Health Clinic to ease
the burden after seeing Australia
struggle with a spike of respiratory
cases in recent months often a marker
for what happens here their children
under nine reported the highest rates of
illness Physicians and public health
experts are urging Canadians to be
proactive it is good to know that
influenza vaccines can be given at the
same time as covid-19 vaccines to people
over five years of age but for parents
whose young kids do get sick they still
face a unique hurdle a cross-country
shortage of over-the-counter pain and
fever medication has persisted for
months at the Alberta Children's
Hospital emergency room staff have seen
the problem push families into the ER
unnecessary early it's really not
helpful if you know for patients or
families to come to the emergency
department to seek those medications
because we don't have more that you can
give at home further strain on a system
limb isn't sure can handle much more we
worry that we're going to get a call and
not be able to to send the child uh to a
place where the help is going to be
available a worst case scenario no
doctor or parent wants to see become a
reality Jamie moroccer Global News
Alberta is lowering the recommended age
for breast cancer screening by five
years it's now among a handful of
provinces and territories to offer
regular screening to women under 50. but
Advocates say the guidelines don't go
far enough and more Canadian women
should have access to regular mammograms
at even younger ages Sarah comedina
reports the late part four years ago
cyan Martin first started having back
pain and couldn't find out why I
actually read a story in a magazine
about a lady that had had back pain
that was and her back pain was caused by
breast cancer that's the mass the 43
year old mother of three found a lump in
her breast one year after her back pain
started she was diagnosed with stage
four breast cancer I have metastases in
my bones pretty much from my skull all
the way down to add to her Devastation
she suspected the diagnosis is months
before she said no no it's not likely to
be cancer you know you're young you
don't have a history the problem is that
17 of breast cancer occurs in the 40s
which is a large amount of the breast
cancer out there Alberta has just
lowered the age from 50 to 45 for women
to begin getting regular mammograms but
even younger could save more lives BC
Pei Nova Scotia and the Yukon all allow
for self-referrals at 40. there is a
push for every Province to follow suit
there are still women who won't survive
but you've got a 44 better chance so
give yourself that chance many provinces
follow the recommendation by the
Canadian task force on preventative
health care that women who are under 50
and not at an increased risk do not need
regular mammograms but patients can ask
for one dense breasts Canada stresses it
shouldn't be a one-size-fits-all
approach black Asian Hispanic women
their Peak incidence of breast cancer is
in the mid 40s compared to white women
whose Peak incidences in the late 50s
early 60s as for Martin she hopes
sharing her experience will help women
advocate for themselves if I'd started
having mammograms at 40 I mean My
outcome could have been quite a bit
different Sarah comedina Global News
Edmonton
some breaking news tonight out of
Burnaby BC where an RCMP officer has
been killed in the line of duty Global's
Carmel karmali is at the scene Kamel
what do we know
well it's a somber mood here the grief
palpable among police officers who are
now tasked with trying to figure out the
circumstances around how one of their
own was killed in broad daylight just
before noon today now what we know so
far is that a female member of the
Burnaby RCMP has been killed after a
stabbing incident details on the victim
are still limited but sources have
confirmed to global news that the
officer was assisting city of Burnaby
bylaw with a call at a park it's very
quiet in this usually busy stretch of
road in Burnaby just outside Vancouver
and as people who live here trying to
come to grips with what happened there's
the Burnaby Board of Education offices
here near a baseball field and a small
park nearby a lot of town homes off of
this stretch of Canada way as well so
it's unclear exactly where this happened
meanwhile BC's minister of Public Safety
is offering his condolences
this is absolutely the worst news
um that
um
could happen
and our hearts go out to the officer's
family the
um the friends the police officers every
day who put their lives on the line
this is just absolutely the worst thing
that you that could happen
Minister farnworth echoing a lot of what
people are feeling here spoke to a
couple of people who work at the Burnaby
Board of Education here they had tears
in their eyes even though they didn't
know the female officer meanwhile need
to this investigation still very much in
its infancy back over to you Carmel
kermallian Burnaby BC tonight thanks
Camille
ottawa's mayor was today's key witness
at the inquiry into the federal
government's invocation of the
emergencies act back in February Jim
Watson who will step down as mayor next
month says he welcomed the controversial
legislation as his City wasn't prepared
for the sheer number of vehicles that
would eventually clog the downtown core
they need to move the trucks out because
we had basically two
transpo large rake trucks tow trucks it
sounds a little bit hokey but you know
when I came out of City Hall after the
emergency act I saw a whole row of tow
trucks parked on Laurier Avenue I
thought I'd never thought I'd see the
day where I'm so happy to see a tow
truck
although he said he's grateful for the
action Watson also aired out numerous
complaints he had with provincial
Federal and security officials during
his hours-long testimony Abigail Beeman
reports
for hours Jim Watson spoke calmly and
carefully we were a bit like the meet
the meat sandwich
ottawa's mayor has Decades of political
experience but also just days left in
office and he voiced multiple concerns
with local police one of the
frustrations I did have with with Chief
slowly when he said this is not going to
be a police solution The Province it was
frustrating that the province was not as
responsive and the FEDS my point was I
can't go and start criticizing The
Province if you still haven't given me a
commitment for the number of offices we
needed from the RCMP
for not getting Convoy trucks out of his
City fast enough it was a teetering on
loss control we lost control in the red
zone it was lawlessness Watson
complained police were slow to tell him
how many officers they needed once he
got a number a letter to the Ontario
Premier shows he asked for 1800 officers
February 7th Watson says it still took
too long to act and that Doug Ford
wouldn't take part in meetings the
premier was adamant that he did not feel
it would be useful to have three
levels of politicians sitting around a
table I I think he felt it would be a
waste of time we've worked
collaboratively with with the mayor and
the the Prime Minister a readout of a
February 8th call with the Prime
Minister shows Justin Trudeau accused
Doug Ford of hiding for political
reasons I share the view that at the end
of the day
um you know both the Prime Minister and
you heard the premiere yesterday of
Ontario say that they were standing
shoulder to shoulder Tuesday's
exhaustive testimony wasn't just about
placing blame the mayor acknowledges
there were many quote failure points
along the way and whether it was the
city The Province or the federal
government Watson says action didn't
happen fast enough nitu Abigail Beeman
reporting tonight thanks Abigail
to Ukraine now the war has entered a
dangerous new phase with Iran emerging
as a key player in the conflict it's
widely suspected Iran is adding drones
to Russia's Arsenal raising tensions
with Western Powers Ukraine says it's
moving to cut diplomatic ties with Iran
after a wave of deadly drone attacks and
there are huge blackouts across the
country from air strikes on the power
grid as Eric Sorensen reports Ukraine
says the situation is critical
cleaning up in kharkiv after a morning
missile attack early today in mikalayev
the aftermath of another Russian missile
strike
while in Kiev and other cities they are
facing new weapons attacks by kamikaze
drones that Ukraine and the West say are
supplied by Iran a new and destabilizing
player in the war on one hand you have
Russia which is uh taking part in a
barbaric illegal and unjust invasion of
another country and on the other hand
you have Iran one that is known for uh
partaking and destabilizing
um violent actions in the region as well
the Kremlin today said it has no
information on the use of Iranian drones
and in Tehran the government denies
sending drones to Russia saying it takes
no side in the Ware
so just three months ago Russia's
president left the country to visit with
the Iranian leader the use of Iranian
drones signals to some a level of
Russian desperation it shows a weakness
in terms of military capacity that
Russia is not able to build these drones
in sufficient quantities in quality
themselves the new Onslaught signals a
turn by Russia to Target civilians and
infrastructure Ukraine says 30 percent
of its power stations have been
destroyed in the last week blackouts are
becoming widespread the two sides are in
an increasingly drawn out fight in the
Eastern regions that are now claimed by
Russia so Russia appears to be mounting
new aerial offensives missile strikes in
mikalayev and denipro and drone strikes
are taking a toll in Kiev and other
cities Vladimir Putin seems to be
shifting from what was a purely military
campaign of aggression to one that
involves a terror Campaign which is
directed largely as civilians at
infrastructure president
Vladimir zielinski is calling again for
more air defenses and NATO says it will
supply them to combat drones
meantime ukrainians are protesting
Iran's involvement in the war but they
are also preparing for what's to come
more Russian attacks and what could be a
cold dark winter Eric Sorensen Global
News
[Music]
and a Norwegian robotics company has
released images it says show the
extensive Damage Done to the largest
route for Russian gas to Europe the
underwater footage shows the twisted and
bent medal from a huge hole in the
ruptured nordstream one pipeline police
in Denmark suspect deliberate explosions
blew four holes in the pipe and its
newer twin nordstream 2 last month the
findings are similar to those of Swedish
officials who've also been investigating
the leaks Russia is denying
responsibility
the worries about an Iranian athlete's
well-being coming up why human rights
activists are concerned for el-naz
recobee's safety
for more than a month now protests have
flared up in Iran and around the world
following the death of Masa amini those
in power have condemned the protests
saying countries like the U.S are to
blame for inciting Terror and chaos and
now there are questions about the
whereabouts of a well-known Iranian
athlete a climber who recently competed
in South Korea without her hijab Redmond
Shannon takes a look at why human rights
activists are worried about her safety
is the latest face of Iran's hijab
protests on Sunday she competed at the
Asian climbing championships in South
Korea without a hijab female athletes
representing Iran are obligated to wear
one BBC Persian reported Monday that
friends had been unable to contact her
an apology appeared on her Instagram
account Tuesday it said her headscarf
fell off after she had to take part in
an event unexpectedly she said she was
flying home recabee's Instagram feed
shows multiple pictures of her covering
her hair but rarely in a full hijab
human rights campaigners think her
actions were no accident what I I
personally think is that she definitely
tried to to show her solidarity with her
Sisters in Iran climbing World governing
body says it supports athletes right to
freedom of Express oppression other
women have been banned from sport in
Iran for not dressing according to
regime rules like soccer player Shiva
amini that punishment will come
definitely if this courage goes away and
most importantly what will happen is
that her professional career will be at
risk the Iranian Embassy in Korea says
it denies all false news about rekhabi's
situation without referring to any
reports in particular the Islamic
Republic has an obligation to protect
children's right to life under any
circumstances on Tuesday the United
Nations said as many as 23 children are
among those who have died in the
Crackdown on anti-regime protests over
the past month a movement sparked by the
death of Masa amini in custody Redmond
Shannon Global News London
enduring summer in October ahead when
will British Columbia's unprecedented
dry spell relent
when most people think about the British
Columbia Coast one of the first things
that comes to mind is rain and lots of
it but this year has been much different
it's now been more than 100 days since
any significant rain fell and as Aaron
McArthur reports between the Wildfire
smoke and ultra low water levels
conditions look more like mid-august
than mid-october
22 000 people on BC's Sunshine Coast
have been living with severe water
restrictions for more than a month under
stage 4 restrictions residents and
Farmers have been banned from using
treated water for all outdoor uses
with almost no rain since the beginning
of July the regional district has been
forced to close the Taps further a local
state of emergency has been declared now
non-essential heavy commercial users of
water will be cut off the intent is
really to focus on make sure that we
have enough water for residents
philosophical for firefighting the
district's pools will be closed
breweries cideries and distilleries are
named in the order along with bottled
water companies and concrete cement and
asphalt operations
businesses affected by the order will be
compelled to stop using treated water
for Persephone Brewing the Water Crisis
has immediate impacts there's enough
stock on hand to last three weeks it's
not just about our bottom lines it's
about trying to keep our people employed
and trying to you know contribute to our
economy on the coast since July 10th the
District of sea Shelt has recorded just
nine millimeters of rain
the average for this period is 200
millimeters
BC has smashed temperature records for
October and smoke from forest fires is
still creating air quality issues
Farmers have taken Extreme Measures by
trying to conserve water
grounded Acres Farm installing storage
for roughly 34 000 liters of water
it was gone in two weeks
without enough water to plant winter
cover crops the situation could still
get worse the viability of the business
is at stake yeah I'm looking at my bare
fields and I'm looking at a lot of rain
coming down and I will lose my topsoil
while there is rain in the forecast it
isn't nearly enough to recharge the
reservoir the level needs to come up
four meters before restrictions can be
removed
Aaron McArthur Global News seashell BC
sharing her fortune next the
multi-billionaire leading the way in
giving it away
[Music]
it is being billed as the Girl Scouts of
America's biggest donation from a single
donor since its founding in 1912. more
than 80 million US Dollars earmarked for
the organization from billionaire
philanthropist Mackenzie Scott as Ross
Lord reports the historic contribution
is just the latest in a long line of
charitable gifts from the former first
lady of Amazon
like most billionaires Mackenzie Scott
would seem to have far more money than
she'll ever truly need but Scott is
doing something many billionaires don't
generously sharing her wealth in a big
way her latest charitable Endeavor is
the largest single gift in the U.S Girl
Scouts history for Scott it follows
donations to hundreds of organizations
ranging alphabetically from groups that
offer free legal advice to ones that
invest in the potential of young people
and many many others in between
465 non-profits converting 3.9 billion
dollars in gifts into services for
others overall donations are more than
twice that amount from a woman who was
once best known as the wife of Amazon
founder Jeff Bezos Scott has rarely
given interviews but while they were
still married she discussed Bezos with
talk show host Charlie Rose he offered
me a job but I interviewed with some
other people and I was offered a job at
another department too so I ended up
taking a different job but then as luck
would have it got assigned an office
right next door to his she divorced
Bezos in 2019 her stake in Amazon is
currently worth an estimated 33 billion
dollars U.S but Scott has plenty of
independent accomplishments she's a
Princeton grad a mother of four an
award-winning novelist you have wanted
to be
writer
[Music]
wrote my first book when I was six but
her gift for giving is defining her
Legacy as a rule she lets her actions
speak for her staying out of the
spotlight encouraging those interested
in her philanthropy to seek out the
organization's she invests in helping
any of us can help us all she wrote in a
public post earlier this year
Scott has promised to give away roughly
half of her Fortune which means billions
more in donations are still to come
Ross Lord Global News
and that is global national for this
Tuesday night I'm nitu garcha tonight
here Canada is the town of Rose Blanche
Harbor La [ __ ] Newfoundland and Labrador
we love seeing your Canada please email
it to viewers globalnational.com thanks
for watching and hope to see you again
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]